Welcome to another Zoom call where we do our best to answer questions that you might
have regarding cancer. And a reminder to use our members page, there wasn't anyone else
once in the last couple of weeks, but many times we'll put new information up there.
Also a reminder to use our blog because I'm constantly adding new blog posts.
So go to our blog on our website, you can access it through our member site as well.
But I'm constantly putting new blog posts up to that I don't always put on the member site.
I think it would be good for the general populist. You can also schedule self-schedule follow-up calls with me as well.
And remember to please fill out the coaching call form whether you call it in schedule
or whether you self-schedule, make sure you fill out the coaching call form.
So we're up to date with what you want to talk about.
Okay, the first question that came in, I hope you had a chance to look over the study on keto and breast cancer metastasis.
Does this look legit? And we should take this and we should we take this to heart.
Those of us doing keto. So this person emailed me a study on ketogenic diets, possibly being harmful to those with breast cancer
and could possibly cause metastasis to breast cancer patients.
And is this legitimate? Yeah, I do think it's legitimate.
But I would request that to say that I am said from the very beginning of time that I am starting to work with cancer patients back in the late 90s.
Is that every cancer is different to say, you know, that's why I have always been against these, you know, books that come out.
Like Siegfried's book that said every single cancer patient should be doing a ketogenic diet.
No, they shouldn't, you know, or every, you know, or Chris works work that every cancer patient should be vegan and be doing juicy or, you know,
a person that everybody should be doing 12, 13 glasses of juice, carrot apple juice on a daily basis.
That's, I just told, I just personally disagree with that. I think everybody is unique.
And the idea that cancer can feed off of certain metabolic pathways is obviously evident.
You know, how come some people do a ketogenic diet and it seems to put a halt on the other cancer?
And some people do a ketogenic diet and you know, the cancer continues to grow because everybody's different and cancer is always looking for a pathway in order to feed itself.
So many times you have to change up when we first initially do a cheek swab testing on somebody and let's say it's just fed through
glycolysis and maybe dairy and we take you off of those things on a low sugar diet and low dairy, no dairy or low dairy.
And a year later it changes and we have to change the diet because it's found a new fuel source.
Not always, but that does exist and it's a possibility.
So we just have to be aware of that. So I would agree that I think that there's cancers that can be fed on a ketogenic diet. Well, what's a ketogenic diet?
Well, you're eating a lot of animal meat and what you're going to get high level of glutamine, which glutamine can be a fuel source for cancer, glutamine and methionine.
Many ketogenic diets also are high in dairy. So this study didn't separate that out because there's a lot of people on a ketogenic diet that are eating meat and dairy.
I mean, that's their biggest thing is they're eating meat, fat and dairy.
A carnivore diet is eliminating the dairy part, but a ketogenic diet certainly isn't. So dairy is going to be a driver of most everybody's cancer because of the growth hormones in it.
So, you know, again, I mean, I am put very new people on a ketogenic diet or it's on there on it for a short period of time and most people that are on a ketogenic diet as far as our patients are brain cancer patients.
So I would agree that this study could show that, but to be honest, you could also probably show a study putting them on the opposite of a ketogenic, a juicy diet and their and their and it can cause bets in some breast cancer patients or colon cancer patients or ladder cancer patients doesn't make any difference.
So because there's a there's a percentage of people in every group, every cancer group that, you know, their cancer is going to be fed mainly off of glutamines and ketogenic diets certainly would be not recommended.
And there's other people in that group that their cancer may be fed mainly directly through glycolysis and therefore, you know, something like a juicy diet would not be recommended.
So you have to understand that changing facet of your cancer always trying to find a fuel source.
Next question, reading about generic oxygen therapy, I'm surprised to find a little to go little to support it as effective on its own against cancer.
There are studies showing effectiveness in conjunction with chemo therapy and radiation, lower in cancer resist cells resistance, but studies that show hypermeric oxygen therapy that's H bot hypermeric oxygen therapy that's you're in a hypermeric oxygen chamber that's what this person's talking about about oxygen therapy.
So hypermeric oxygen therapy is an effectiveness on its own, don't seem to exist, is this what you have found also.
So, you know, I've also said this before, it's hard to get a study approved unless you're, unless you're combining it with chemotherapy or radiation.
So if you're going to combine, you know, if you're going to do a study on curcumin as a beneficial nutrient for cancer patients, most a lot of the studies that you're going to Google and find out there are studies that are saying people who are on chemotherapy and doing curcumin are do do better than people that are on chemotherapy and are not doing curcumin.
Well, what about those who are doing chemotherapy? Well, they couldn't get approval for their study and they can't get study dollars money to run a study unless it's tied with chemotherapy or radiation.
That's just the financial situation with trying to get the national institutes of health to authorize a study and to get funding government to fund because mostly studies that are done on cancer are done with governmental grants or they're funded by the drug company itself.
So, what's the benefit of a drug company who sells chemotherapy to fund a study using HBOT with chemotherapy? Well, the reason is is that they realize that there's a large percentage of people that are going to use curcumin and green tea extract and burberry and HBOT and things.
So, they might as well cash hit on that and they do it. They do a study that is done with chemotherapy and radiation.
They're by giving evidence that and giving information to the general public that you of course everybody does chemotherapy and radiation.
So, it's kind of a mind game that they play with people too. So, it is difficult to find research and I've said this multiple times before that unless you couple research with chemotherapy and radiation meaning unless you couple research with current standards of care, it's going to be difficult to get a study approved.
And number two, it's going to be difficult to get funding to do a study. It's very expensive to do a study. People have asked why are there more studies on rife technology because there's no money in it.
And to get a study approved for something that costs a lot of money and they're not going to approve a study on doing rife therapy versus doing chemotherapy or they're not going to approve the study doing HBOT versus doing chemotherapy or curcumin versus chemotherapy.
They're never going to approve that study. It's never going to be approved. Why? Because the drug companies control the national instance of health. You'll never get approval to do a study like that because quite honestly they be afraid of the outcome.
So, and then secondly, you won't get funding. So, you just kind of have to understand that.
How could someone have elevated iron levels, but low hematocrit, low hemoglobin and other signs of anemia? I thought if you had anemia, your iron would be low too.
Well, most of the time, yes, iron deficiency anemia is called iron deficiency anemia because you have a deficiency in iron.
And I did put up a blog post and I think I did put it up on the member site some tell tell signs of anemia on a general blood test.
But this is a little bit of a twist that is interesting. A person could have all signs of anemia, low hemoglobin, low hematocrit, low red blood cells.
Elevated MCV, low MCV, low MCHC, low MCH, and then elevated mean cell width, which would be all signs of anemia.
But they could have this twist of elevated iron.
So, your iron that this person is talking about is what's called serum iron. So, it's what you do a blood test and they're measuring your blood level of iron.
Serum iron is is traveling around in your blood bound to a protein called transform.
So, it's it's bound in your blood and it's carried about in your blood when you absorb it.
Now, most iron that you take in through your food is is absorbed in your first part of your small intestine and it is it's necessary for you to have good hydrochloric acid in order for you to absorb iron.
So, one side of low one one issue with a person with low iron would could be a decrease hydrochloric acid content to their stomach.
But why would a person have elevated iron? So, the first thing you think of with elevated iron is a condition called hemicromatosis.
Now, that's a genetic condition and you think a genetic condition is always going to be diagnosed for the person is young, but that's not true.
Because you could have a mild form of hemicromatosis and you never knew it and you didn't get this diagnosed till you were 60 years old, you started getting blood tests for some other reason.
You could also have hemociderosis, which is more of an acute elevation of iron and iron overload.
Now, the treatment for elevated iron when you don't have other signs of anemia, that's what this question is about, they have other signs of anemia.
The treatment for hemicromatosis would be actually going and giving blood donating blood on a monthly basis.
But when a person has elevated iron but then other signs of anemia of their blood work, it's not hemicromatosis, it's an iron conversion issue.
So, they're not converting iron in their blood. So, it's being stuck in their blood and they're not getting it to their tissues.
So, that's a different issue. Now, that can actually be part of a B12 deficiency or a B6 deficiency.
So, there can be other issues with that. So, when a person has elevated iron but all other signs of anemia, they still have anemia but they have an iron conversion problem.
So, the serum iron being elevated with a decreased red blood cell, decreased hemoglobin, hematocrit and other signs, is the inability of in the body to convert the inorganic type of iron found in the serum found to transfer it into the organic hemoglobin necessary to be carried out throughout the body.
So, it's probably a need for vitamin B12, maybe even folate, B6, and if cancer, I'd say copper as well.
So, but those are the things that you'd look at with elevated iron and then all signs of anemia.
Next question. Are there any issues with adding fendizol protocol to my current supplement protocol?
Typically, there's no issues if a person wanted to add fendizol to their protocol or if they wanted to add Ivermectin to their protocol.
Except that which we've talked about in the past, you'd want to get a complete metabolic panel done on a more regular basis.
So, you want to look at both your liver markers and your kidney markers because now you're taking a drug.
Well, it's not a very high dose if a fendizol is to dose that a 10-pound dog would take.
Still, it's a drug, it's a medication that can be difficult for your liver to process.
So, a lot of people that have liver issues or if you have genetic issues with your liver, you don't process certain drugs very well.
And it can cause an elevation of your ASTL, ALT and alkaline phosphatase.
So, you want to look at those, you can have issues with your, with your kidney markers as well.
So, you want to make sure that you're keeping an eye on that.
So, as long as you are willing to get more regular blood work or what's more regular, well get some blood work before you start that.
So, we can see a baseline of those markers and maybe then a month in after doing that protocol.
Or if you're having any increased symptoms of like pain in your liver or anything, get another blood test to make sure you don't have a spike of those markers.
So, if you could keep those markers within balance, you don't see any problem adding those therapies to your current protocol.
So, if the question is, is Fennbedozo or Iverback going to negatively affect the supplements I'm taking, the answer would be no.
So, in that sense, there's no issue with adding those.
The only issue is that it could affect your liver, so you want to make sure you keep an eye on that.
Next question, can a person use the rice machine too much?
Well, the easy answer to that is no.
We have some patients that have been hospitalized that I've written long programs.
I mean, literally wrote programs that were, you know, over 70 hours long.
That said that they didn't have to turn it on and off, you know, very often.
So, it was just running constantly while the person was in their hospital bed.
The easy answer is no, you don't know, you know, way you could do too much.
But the more depth answer is, it really depends on what program you're running.
So, if you're running cancer programs, the answer is no, you really can't do too much right feet.
But if you're running kill programs, what's a kill program?
So, if you're running like parasite kill programs or bacterial kill programs,
especially if it's gram negative bacteria like Lyme disease, yes, you could do too much.
So, if we have a patient that comes to us and they want me to program the rice machine for their Lyme disease,
then I would say, okay, well, we have to go really slow and we have to maybe,
we have to do sometimes multiple changes to the program.
Sometimes I've given the person right off the bat, multiple different programs,
where you start off with a very short amount of kill in the program of overnight program.
There's a lot more detox frequencies in that program.
And then we, you know, as they can tolerate that, then we go up with higher kill rate times
as far as that being able to tolerate that.
Because when you kill a gram negative bacteria too quickly, you'll liberate life of polysaccharides
and that would cause a hurt cyber reaction.
And you don't want to do that with people with Lyme disease.
So, with Lyme disease patients, yes, you could do too much rifing.
If you're running bacteria kill programs.
So, could a Lyme disease patient run detox programs and overdose on the detox programs?
No, no, you can't because the detox programs in the rites are mainly to stimulate liver function and kidney function.
They're not like key lady stuff out of your tissue and could overwhelm your detox pathways.
That's not how the rife works.
And that's what's in everybody's cancer program understands.
So, in your cancer program, I have some detox things in your cancer program as well,
but mainly you're running cancer frequencies all night long.
And you're recycling those frequencies.
So, if you wouldn't search through the different your your program and looked at all those numbers,
each night is actually similar.
You know, so I mix it up so that if you have the reason why it makes it up is like,
okay, you're going to bed at night and maybe people are very habitual.
They go to bed at night at clock every night and they get up at one o'clock to go to the bathroom.
But they're in the bathroom for, you know, half hour.
And they would miss their program frequencies from one to one to 30 every single night.
Well, tomorrow's the frequencies are going to be different at that time.
So, they're mismatched around so you won't miss them or a person's like,
I never end up finishing my program because I always end up getting up early and it's still running
and I missing frequencies.
Well, if you're getting up three hours early every day, yeah, we should probably shorten your program.
But if you're sometimes finishing the program and sometimes getting up half hour early
and sometimes, you know, getting up 15 minutes early, I mean, don't worry about it
because you're getting those programs mixed up in there.
But every cancer patient, the majority of the frequencies in their program are cancer programs.
There's some liver cleanse, there's some different things depending on the cancer that person had.
Sometimes depending upon our initial conversation.
And often when when I rewrite a program for a person, it's depending upon what tested out with that.
Or maybe a conversation I had with them, maybe they're having new issues.
So I'll put different other things in that program.
But for a cancer patient, no, it's never, you could never do too much right feet.
We have some cancer patients that might be listening to this call right now that are running it all night long.
They're running it all day long because they're not really, you know, very ambulatory.
And if you're not going to be, you know, if you're going to be sitting watching TV or reading a book,
you should be running the right, getting as much right time in as possible.
And I've stated many times that the big error that people make is that they are not running the right enough.
Sometimes we can purchase right machines back and I can look and see, you know, how often the person ran their program.
And many times, you know, if a person passes away, they've run their program a lot.
And that's, that's great. And we did gave it everything we could.
And we gave it our best shot. We know that was sad when I get what I get a right back from a spouse who has passed away.
And they haven't run the right for eight months. It's like, what? I don't, I don't understand.
If you have this machine, you should be using it in the, and it's going to do you zero good.
And you're not running it is as much as you possibly can.
I stated many times when I was at my sickest, I was running it all night long.
I dragged to work and then I turned the right on at work. I had it on all day at work.
And then I'd get home and I turned it on immediately when I got home.
So I was running the right some days, at least 20 hours a day.
And I attribute that to really getting me over my cancer.
So, and putting me in a state of revision that I am in.
So you can't do too much cancer rifing long story.
Long answer to that. But next question.
I saw that you said that I could eat meat, but I've been staying away from meat since my cancer diagnosis.
Since I read things that said it would be bad for a cancer patient to eat red meat and that red meat especially causes cancer.
Why the change are these things true?
Can red meat cause cancer?
The easy answer to that is no.
Can toxins in poor quality red meat cause cancer?
Yes, but can the proteins of an animal cause cancer?
No.
Can poor quality red meat filled with toxins from what the animal is eating be a cause of cancer?
Yes.
Again, there's stuff on the internet similar to the earlier question that say, you know, no cancer patients should be eating meat every cancer person should be you should go vegan right away never eat meat meat is bad.
There's books written about it.
What was that the China syndrome or what was it?
But that was totally debunked.
That was that book and that author was funded by PETA.
I just totally disagree when you make blanket statements now there's some there's some honest blanket statements you know should should cancer patient any patient with cancer be eating a lot of dairy.
Well, probably not because dairy contains growth hormones.
But does that mean that dairy is a driver for my cancer?
Not necessarily.
Does it mean every every cancer patient should absolutely avoid dairy like they're allergic to it? No.
And to make statements like okay no cancer patient should be eating meat everybody should go on this vegan diet or like the question before every cancer patient should be on a keto diet so they're eating tons of meat.
I just think that's wrong.
I just think that we were created to have a balance.
And part of the reason that we could have some health issues not just cancer is because we do get out of balance in our life.
There is a balance that we need to seek now cancer can be fed through certain metabolic pathways and those metabolic pathways which feed a certain cancer can change as well like I stated before so in general though should cancer patients avoid meat.
I don't think so I think that's a wrong statement right there should some cancer patients avoid meat yes because if your cancer is fed through glutamine and with iodine then you should avoid meat.
However, in order for you to make an order for cancer patient to make the specific type of red, excuse me specific type of white blood cells to kill cancer.
They need adequate amounts of protein could you obtain those amounts of protein through a vegan diet yes you could it would be much more difficult.
In order for you to kill cancer cells you need a subset of lymphocytes that are called T cells and another subset called natural killer cells.
Now those subsets in order for your body to produce those is completely in very dependent upon protein consumption.
Much of the research shows that you need to be consuming your weight or your desired weight if you're under weight in the grams of protein per day meaning that if you weigh 150 pounds you need to be consuming 150 grams of protein a day in order to make adequate natural killer cells and T cells in order to kill cancer.
Well it's kind of hard to do if you're on a vegan diet so eating a piece of chicken you know it's going to give you 40 grams of protein right there so you can get your 150 grams of protein you know much easier if you're eating meat.
Now of course we're talking about is clean meat as you possibly can grass fed beef isn't going to contain good omega fatty acids which is very essential for you in your diet is going to contain building blocks for those that have anemia.
Anemia and cancer is extremely common and you can help build back your blood by eating red meat so I'm not against eating red meat.
When I have patients when I test them with the with the cheek swab sometimes they test by their cancer being fed through glutamated with iodine and we do take away meat that was personally my cancer it was fed through that and I stopped eating meat for a period of time until it didn't test anymore that I went back to eating meat.
I don't think it's healthy for the average person to be on a vegan diet.
But for cancer patients to be on a vegan diet when their cancer is not fueled through with iodine and glutamate I think it's very difficult to get your nutrients and to keep your energy up.
Next question hello and thank you for all your help if a person's cancer is progressing while using the true right would you recommend getting the atelier Robin machine or getting new programming for the true right Scott has been using the true right for.
Little over two years.
So you know we've most people that are listening to me right now are using the true right we've used the true right machine since I don't know 2008 or something I can't remember I just talked to somebody on the phone
about late last week that we they needed a new computer for their right but I said you know you're not even in our new software that we use for our patients.
Remind me again when you started with me she said I think it was 10 12 years ago so she's been doing well for a long time and her but her bulb went out and her computer went out.
I've been using the true right for a very long time because I've always promised to my patients that I would always use the best machine that I think that's out there in the market before true right Camaro when I first started with this.
We started with a beam ray in a light beam generator now those would be extremely antiquated machines at this point in the discussion.
My old beam ray machine honestly like what I had still had my storage unit oh gosh this is like it years ago I ended up growing it away because I couldn't consciously sell it to anybody in good conscience it's like there's just no way there's just no way I can I never going to use this again I just tossed it so.
So true right true right was the best on the market for a very long time now I'm convinced the atelier Robin is a better machine for multiple reasons and I share some of those reasons on the frequency course.
It should a person get switched to the atelier Robin if they have a true right.
Well if they're doing well and they're staying stable I would say absolutely not no I don't think it's that big of a difference if you're doing well.
If I'm not doing well and my cancer is progressed and it just took off again should that be something I consider if you can financially do it maybe it would be something I would consider.
Because I do think that it adds enough extra benefit so in a perfect world if there was no cost to them and to upgrade them I'd say everybody should upgrade it but there's a cost still costs me money to do that I can't just give machines away for free it's just not possible but the benefit of the atelier Robin is it allows us to do.
Harmonic frequencies so that's one benefit so a harmonic frequency is doing two frequencies at the same time and one so a harmonic frequency is a is a mathematical equation of you don't believe that frequency tripling that frequency quadrupling that frequency etc.
And there's evidence that running harmonics with the frequency can add benefits.
The big information out there is running what's called the 11th harmonic which is 11 times that frequency let's have running frequency of 2000 so the 11th harmonic is going to be 22,000 so you're running 22,000 Hertz I'm talking about Hertz.
So you're running that frequency let's say you're already 2000 and 22,000 at the same time overlapping each other it could have a big benefit when you're trying to kill pathogens living things living cells so the benefit that we have with the atelier Robin is that I can write your program running the 11th harmonic so that we are covering more basis to be able to have a better chance to kill.
The cancer.
So that's a super exciting feature that we have with the atelier Robin.
The other feature that I think is makes the atelier Robin more superior is the true right only goes up to about 10 to 12,000 Hertz that's the most you could go up with the bulb.
Any other higher frequencies you have to do with the foot bath and it can only go up to about 30,000 with the foot bath.
With the atelier Robin we could go up to 30,000 Hertz with the bulb which were then catching all of life's original frequencies with the bulb.
And then with the foot bath if you wanted to add the foot bath you could go up to 100,000 actually a million Hertz with the foot bath.
Now I don't even with the atelier Robin I don't even recommend the foot bath.
So though we have a number of people with the atelier Robin that wanted to have the foot bath also which is fine, but I don't think you need the foot bath with the atelier Robin.
So but so there's and then there's several other benefits with the atelier Robin that we could get into as well.
So but just for me to say oh that's it you just need this new machine that's what's going to turn your cancer around that would that would be a lie.
I don't I can't say that that would be a promise that I could not make so I couldn't say that if it was me and money wasn't an issue could I buy it until if I was my cancer was going the wrong way when I run it but I get it until the atelier Robin.
Yes again everybody here knows if you were if you were in this group what my cancer was bad I was still doing zoom calls and I was sharing with you my protocol and exactly what I was doing I was running I just told you before I was running the true right all night long.
I got to work and I run I ran the gb 4000 us a different machine that allows you to go higher frequencies because it's using a totally different technology um um but you it has lots of negatives.
I did never I never recommended buying a gb 4000 for people because it has a whole bunch other negatives but I know how to run the gb 4000 so I run the gb 4000 during the day.
And run the true right for night because I had the true right at home you can't the running the gb 4000 you can't run it all day long.
That was one of the big negatives of the gb 4000 now I would never recommend the gb 4000 now that we have the atelier Robin because it's like the gb 4000 and the true right had a baby and and the baby is much brighter.
So um but yeah in a perfect world yeah I would I would try an atelier Robin that's what I would do um but but you know it everybody's different so if you're sitting here listening to this and going oh I have a true right should I trade my true right fit if you're doing well I'd say no no you should it well I don't know if I'm doing well you know I'm you know I've just had it for six months or so and I've just been tried well just keep going here.
And we'll keep testing you know so I don't know I don't have any data on people and I've had a true right and then have changed to the atelier Robin and their in their cancer turned around because we have never tried that yet on anybody okay because the atelier Robin machine is only four months old so um it's I don't know if it would make that big of a difference quite honestly I just I can't say yes or no.
Um if it was me and I was in your situation I would do it but it also depends on a person's financial situation so um you know that's what I've said in in past Zoom calls a lot of people are a lot of people get two right machines they have one up in their bedroom and then they have one down to their living room well if you're thinking about getting a second right machine buy it at the atelier Robin.
So if I have people call me on a case review and they're like talking to me and they're like I want to get a right machine which one I what should I get I'll say in a tell your Robin if they say which I've had this happen no no people said no I want to get a true right my sister had a true right but it was then okay let's get you a true right I love true right okay but I just love until your Robin more so um that's that's my record.
That's my recommendation I have never compared the two we don't we don't I mean as far as it uh hey study or anything like that I would never jeopardize somebody's health to do so um so I I can't tell you you know we heard honestly you see all our testimonials we have hundreds and hundreds of people that have had phenomenal success with our therapies but I've also sat in the past two that I you know to be honest
I don't know if was the right that that helped that person heal cancer or was it you know their supplements or was it their loving spouse or was it um the combination of chemo or was it their attitude or was it their belief I don't know and we've seen miracles with animals with the true right so there was no placebo effect whatsoever the dog got better how do you explain that one they didn't do anything else but do the right
and it was the true right um so the true right is a phenomenal tool so I don't want to make anybody think that they need to run out and make changes but if you are thinking about getting a second one or if your cancer is progressing you're willing to try something else then by all means that would be the choice question from the chat if a current member would want to purchase the teleravon at some point
what would be that cost you'll just have to call Angie and talk to her about that we would give you um uh slight discount because of the programming but the programming for after it wouldn't be a big discount because the programming for the teleravon is different
so I'm adding the 11th harmonic to the program and so I'm rewriting your whole program so would your program would be different
than your true right program I've been using whole a homemade copper strap on my foot for grounding
will I sleep will I sleep should wall I think wall I sleep I think that's what you meant
okay I'm using a homemade copper strap on my foot for grounding while I sleep should I stop I know you
didn't like copper and some of the things I was taking before so no a copper strap on your foot
to a grounding to a ground in the wall that's grounded to your electrical that's grounded to the ground
is just fine you're not gonna absorb any copper you're very little copper through your skin so you're
fine with that you can keep doing that why shouldn't the person who has cancer be consuming a lot of copper why
shouldn't the person with cancer be using copper pans why shouldn't the person with cancer be taking supplements with copper
because copper is good for you right you need copper well first of all copper is good for you you need
copper what does copper do it excites growth so why does the cancer patient want to be careful
of the about a copper they're exposed to because you don't want to be excited growth so therefore I
don't like a person to have a lot of copper in your supplement so obviously a whole food supplement
might have a little copper because it's in the food that you're eating you're getting copper in your
food that you're eating um that's just fine the idea of person using copper pans or copper cups I've
seen Instagram videos where people are saying oh I use a copper cup because copper is so good for you
that's just idiotic because that's elemental copper that's not useful to eat your copper we're
gonna chew chew on a piece of copper I think that's good for you no copper is in the soil and then
plants take copper bond it to a double bond glycine atom and then we eat the plant we don't eat
elemental copper it's like iron people could go well I use an iron um pan to cook with because
iron is good for us no no that's not how you get your iron it's not wrong with using an iron pan
but that's not how you would get your iron you don't suck on a piece of iron to get your iron that's
elemental iron you can't absorb that it's probably going to cause constipation issues and such
you get iron through your food and if you're going to take an iron supplement because you have low
iron or iron deficiency anemia you would take an iron supplement that's in the that's in the
form that you would get it in food not in by pee the piece of iron so it's not a nonsense out there so
just be careful of that but using a copper strap on your foot there's no problem with that you're
not absorbing any of that copper and copper is a good conductor of electricity so it's a good
way for you to ground I've experienced constipation after finishing an eastern protocol
and starting my new rife program magnesium citrate and vitamin C crystals have helped but also I've
gotten kidney stone pains the rife helps get rid of pains though
so let's stop there a second so if a person has constipation one therapy to use is magnesium with
vitamin C if the reason is is that magnesium if you take if you take excess magnesium you will dump
that magnesium back into the colon magnesium being an iron will then draw water and it will help
and loosen your stools and you'll have better moments but a person with kidney stones is trying to be
careful of you know excess mineral consumption so they don't want to necessarily be doing magnesium
and somebody even a cancer protocol doesn't necessarily want to be taking vitamin C because you're trying
to stay away from antioxidants if you're doing an oxidative therapy so what do you do let's finish
this question I received my protocol from you today and we'll start it tomorrow will this help with
my bowel movements or should I try some of the other things in my binder the enemas work but I would have
to do them almost daily to help with bowel movements so I don't know I doubt that I have gave you anything
in your protocol for if you're having constipation issues now taking a digestive enzyme that
very very well might be in your protocol it would be probably called clear digest that could very well
help with bowel movements so why does a person get constipation well there's multiple reasons
person gets constipation because they're not eating enough fiber they can be constipated
person gets constipation because they just have a lot of inflammation in their gut person gets
constipation because they have a weakness of parasitic waves the parasitic waves are the
constriction of the muscles around the gut to help you move your feces through the bowel and what
controls the parasitosis is the vagal nerve so it's the it's cranial nerve 10 the vagus nerve the
vagal nerve is your parasympathetic nervous system so doing coffee enemas it could help with constipation
two ways that physical liquid in your colon can soften things up in your lower part of the
colon and your descending colon particularly and in the sigmoid colon and it can help move things
through but the other thing is that coffee enemas will stimulate the vagal nerve down at the rectal
area the vagal nerve cranial nerve 10 stimulates the parasympathetics which is going to stimulate
parasitosis you can do other things that should be in your binder that talk about
help with constipation the easiest thing the the cheapest and the simplest is a product that we
private labeled phase six assist it's it's a super hello product which is a specific type of
aloe that will help loosen your balls so aloe vera you think of as you know really good for your
gut so what is aloe vera it's from a aloe plant it could help heal your intestinal tract it could help
heal your your skin it's really good for birds etc but there's a whole bunch of different varieties
of aloe the aloe that we're talking about for your gut is a type of aloe called cape aloe so that's
not necessarily healing your intestinal tract but it's it's a great tool for loosening your bowel
person could use sedate sedate is an herb that will help with constipation but I don't like long-term
use of that because it can cause issues on your gut wall so it can be hard on your gut wall sedate
also stimulates parasitic waves and that can cause cramping and you could just feel like oh my
stomach is just killing me so I'm not a super big fan of sedate there's another herb called cascaira
sigrada that's a good herb to help with bowel movements but that can be hard on your bowel long-term too
it's much less expensive it easier to use cape aloe because it's pretty cheap and cape aloe
it's you know we have one that's made by ortho molecular we private label it you might get it in
ortho molecular label super aloe they make it in two forms they make the 250 milligram and 450
milligram we have another product that has only 50 milligrams of cape aloe in it but if a person
has constipation issues you should get one of the larger ones typically if you take one if you're
like really bad constipation issues if you try to take it to in the evening you don't need to take
me easy with it take two in the evening you're gonna have bowel movements next day probably multiple
and you might go well that was too much I went like six times today so maybe you'll take one in the
evening we have people that are on two or those we have some people that are on an auto ship of the
super aloe 450 and I don't know they have serious constipation issues that you know they maybe they
need to eat more fiber too but will the protocol that you're on help with the constipation maybe
maybe not it's a good idea to have some of that cape aloe in your in your cupboard my wife and I
have to have the cape aloe in our cupboard and you know you don't have to use it you know once in a
while but if you eat something that is very constipated you feel like you got new regular usually
because you ate something that was inflammatory to your gut that you shouldn't have any eating
then getting it out it's getting it's taking some cape aloe can be good many times as people that are
eating something a food that they're sensitive to that is actually a cause of constipation so
um figuring that out and dealing with that can be beneficial as well that was our last question any
other questions you can feel free to use the chat box and chat in your question or coconut products
okay for a low histamine diet you know that's again that's something that you like if you google
foods with high histamine in it you could you could pull up like six different articles so there's
six different lists there'll be some common things in each list but sometimes you'll go this list has
this in it and it doesn't have this list doesn't have that in it because if you do organic
assay of products to test for histamines you know I've said this before it's
sometimes it's very different because it depends on how old the product is etc and how
the histamines are in it so the percentage of histamines in a product is based upon the age of the
product is just based upon the you know the sample that you got of that product coconut is that high
in histamines I don't think it's generally high in histamines so um but you know if you eat too much
anything you can have problems so but you know is coconut oil a substitute for some other things
uh or could I have coconut in a meal that I make yeah I think they're I think that would be
typically fine on a high histamine diet within a reason what are the best ways to get the blood
sugar level lowered so if you're testing your blood glucose levels number one make sure
you're testing it in a fast-eating state and make sure you're testing it kind of well the same time
every day because your blood sugar is good to go up after you eat so make sure you don't make that
mistake and you and you're testing it too short of a time you know after you've eaten so um
boy and if you've been at a good lower carbohydrate diet and your blood glucose levels are still high
sometimes you could do everything right and you still can't get that blood glucose level down
partly because of there's well there's many different factors in blood glucose level there's new
types of uh functional testing out there called homea testing it's um homeostatic metabolic assessment
two that's what it's called homea two and um it is and there's it's new markers to help a person
assess to assess help a doctor assess a patient um when their insulin levels are normal and their
glucose level is is more in syndrome x which would be considered free diabetic state so you're trying
to help assess the person and get them on a changed diet but generally to lower a person's glucose
levels your your decreasing your carbohydrate loan first of all and you're trying to eat more things
that have a lower glycemic index that are breaking down into glucose uh that are taking longer to
break down to glucose so like even if I'm going to eat a potato if I cook a potato and then refrigerate
it or freeze it and then heat it up and eat it tomorrow it's going to have more resistant starch and
it's going to have a lower glycemic index than if I could dip a potato and eat the potato so
you're keeping an eye on gleece glycemic index levels generally keeping an eye on your carbohydrate
consumption is going to be the best way to do that but you might be a person like many people like
I've been doing that for years and I cannot get my glucose levels down well there can be some nutrients
that could help you that's one of the reasons why I'm such a big one reason why I'm such a big
band of burberry burberry it is a great nutrient to help lower blood glucose levels and help
take some burden off of patients that are struggling with diabetes. Burberry is also a killer of H
pylori. Burberry is a killer of cancer. Burberry is a balancer of your gut. Burberry does a lot of great
things but what does one thing it helps bring glucose levels down. There's other nutrients that
can help bring glucose levels down. So and then you got to consider why the glucose level is up. Could
it be stress on the pancreas? So the pancreas is struggling even though your insulin levels are
number higher that's one of the benefits of doing a index homea 2 test which because I could give you
some percent insulin resistance and percent insulin stress on that test though I mean I never
typically recommend that test because all our patients are already motivated to be on a fairly good
diet but that test is good for people who maybe don't have cancer but aren't really motivated
to be on a good diet but then you could show things before they're got full diabetes that they're
that they're kind of heading to that direction by doing that test. So trying to get your blood sugar
levels lowered you could use specific nutrients with it and mainly through diet
but and then there's some people with that insulin resistant issue that it's really hard to do that
so then supporting the pancreas we've seen that happen before by people that are diabetic and
they can't get their levels lowered by putting them on basically a Dr. Kelly pancreatic enzyme
approach diet to help help support take a lot of stress off their pancreas has been proven with
some people to help as well. Next question I believe you mentioned in a phone call with me that
when the cancer settles down we will address some of the other issues how will I know when the
cancer settles down would you be able to address neuropathy with the right machine.
So there are some issues that you can do simultaneously of course so let's say if I have um
cancer and let's say my cancer is really active so I'm really working hard you know with
most of my protocols to deal with the cancer but I also have an autoimmune issue. Sometimes it's
difficult to address that autoimmune issue at the same time at least to a certain degree why
because if we're stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer we could also be at many times
we are stimulating the immune system to to cause the autoimmune disease to be more layered so if I have
cancer I want to stimulate the immune system to kill the cancer but if I have an autoimmune disease
if I do things that stimulate the immune system I'm going to cause more self-destruction
so in that case it'd be hard to you know but you could still make some changes like
while let's look at food sensitivities that could be stimulating my immune system that's not
helping my cancer that could actually be hindering my cancer while I would be helping my autoimmune
disorder then by doing that so we can still could currently treat some things but like a cancer
and autoimmune disease is more difficult other things like cancer and you know stomach issues or cancer
and you know bowel issues or cancer and infections cancer and parasites very easily treated
concurrently it can be you know combined to what could be totally causing the person issues
cancer and neuropathy same thing so are there frequencies on the right for neuropathy yes if you look
at the alphabetical list there are some frequencies for neuropathy what else can be done for neuropathy
so neuropathy remember is so if a person has neuropathy that's induced by chemotherapy
induced by this poison that they took into kill their cancer well that poison damaged the peripheral
nerves because it's settling in there and I think I had to talk about neuropathy a few weeks ago
on a zoom call helping detox that is going to be helpful and then stimulating the nerves is essential
other the most common reason for neuropathy is diabetic induced neuropathy so high levels of blood
sugar the nerves are very sensitive to that and can be damaged by that quite easily and it's going
to be the peripheral nerves where that where that blood is going to pool where that sugar is going to
pool where the damage is going to occur so it's going to be neuropathy of the peripheral nerves
farthest from the heart so you have to stimulate the nerves in order to wake them up in order to get
them to grow in order to get them to heal so stimulating the nerves can be done concurrently with
treated cancer there's no contraindication there you could use tools like vibration to stimulate
the nerves we see a lot of diabetic neuropathy patients in the past we'd have them get these little
vibration footplates that I don't know if they're available on Amazon anymore but they used to be
like a couple hundred bucks or 150 bucks on Amazon and they just vibrate and you could put them
by your chair that you sit down at watch TV or whatever and you just turn it on and it just vibrate
it and you get put your feet out there with with just your socks on not your shoes and it's vibrating
stimulating those nerves so stimulating nerves is what causes them to fire and causes them to grow
so your peripheral nerves have receptors that are for hot and cold so put in your feet in hot water
cold water very good so you have hot and cold receptors you have vibratory receptors
and those those stimulating those are beneficial and then you can stimulate them with electrical therapy
as well so there's a tool called the rebuilder it's a tool and we've sold for oh gosh a decade or so
um for neuropathy that's all it's for and it stimulates the nerves at their frequency
electrically you have to get a split bath of water so you get one of those like tote
things that you can buy at Walmart and on our store you could buy the rebuilder and it shows a
picture of what you should buy at Walmart these little tote things and you put the rubber pads one
at each side fill it with water put your feet in there and you turn the rebuilder on it you'll feel
this tingle like a like a little electrical stem you can't you're not gonna electrocute yourself it's
only a nine volt battery but you're running this thing you turn it up to tolerance and you're
stimulating those nerves for 15 to 30 minutes a day and it really does work it is it is an FDA approved
device for neuropathy it really does work so that's another thing that you could use for neuropathy
next question there are a lot of companies out there that offer continuous glucose monitors with an
app for your phone like kc means levels and mark diamond function or something do you have an opinion on
these programs in general or recommend one they're expensive but may uh if maybe if done for a few
months can lend some insights and individual blood sugar effects of foods um yeah i mean if you
have a continuous glucose monitor if people that are diabetes but at times they're insurance will pay for
that you could use that um do and i think you need to do i think you need to be that obsessed with your
glucose levels if you are not diabetic no i don't think you need to be that obsessed with your
glucose levels like i said before that's the goal of a cancer patient to get their glucose levels
down into the 80s or 70s that would be optimal that you're gonna have the optimal starvation of a
cancer if your glucose levels are in the 70s i don't think you need to get into a ketogenic state where
you're only burning ketones in order to starve a cancer um but for a lot of people especially if
you're a little older it's almost impossible to get into ketosis into true ketosis even if you're
completely 100% on a ketogenic diet so um because there's issues with insulin resistance over time
where your cells have been damaged the cell membranes are replicating cells with damaged cell membranes and
you could never get into that state and people have issues um especially as we age you know if you have
we don't for a 22-year-old patient with brain cancer going into ketogenic they probably get into
ketosis if they're strict other diet you know very short period of time people that are older
stay at a very strict almost ketogenic diet can sometimes can never get into ketosis why is that
because the cell membranes are are just never healthy enough to do that so um even by doing
it is everything right some people are like I do everything right I don't eat any carbs I'd
stick on a very strict diet and they can't seem to bunch their glucose below 90 um and they're on
burberry they'd probably a bigolidate and everything that you can think of that would be possible
to help lower glucose levels and they still can't get it lower and it's because of
multiple factors but it's mainly health of the of the cell membranes that is probably never
going to change for that person so um do you need a continuous glucose monitor?
no I don't think so and I don't recommend that you should be taking your glucose levels every
morning either you don't need to be obsessed about it ultimately with with your diet with your
cancer protocol you want to do everything you can to do what's right and ultimately we have to
rest and leaving the results to God there is a level of trust and faith involved in healing
involved in everything we do I mean do I you know have a you know do I use precaution when I drive
home at work of course I do do I turn my lights on when it's a little bit at dusk but certainly not
dark yeah I do because it's the wise thing to do so you make wise decisions and I always drive on
the correct side of the road you're making wise decisions but if I'm obsessed and worried and
and making it spending too much time and too much energy and uh too much created too much anxiety
in my life over certain things like in this case getting my glucose levels down with it not necessarily
in a state of active cancer um then then you have to say that my level of anxiety over this thing
could be the cause of you know an increased cancer growth so you have to keep that balance in life
so you know even when I was at my worst and my health was at its worst and I thought for sure that
I only had a couple months left on this earth no matter how hard it is you have to rest in the fact
that we serve a sovereign God he is holy he is good I will do everything on my part within reason
once I cross over that imaginary line of obsession uh and tried to gain health and that line is
in a different place in everybody's life but we have to be careful not to cross that line where
where health and healing of this disease is becomes idolatry then it's unhealthy and then the
anxiety that we have that we are undergoing and doing so can be actually a driver of my cancer
so um that's hard that's hard for everybody and and I'm not here telling everybody where that line is
in their life um I think you should keep trying to keep asking and keep trying to figure this out
you know just you know just give up and and die but you but you also how do you get to a point where
I'm trusting God and knowing that you know I'm resting in him too and I'm that's we're having that
relationship with him is so important that you can ask him Lord tell me how far to go here tell me
what I should do it's like asking that question should I buy another machine should I do another
program should I do this you tell me where to go I want to be obedient above all things and that's
that's the most important thing my most important thing is to die and get to have it in here well done
with faithful servant not hey you were lazy and you didn't do everything you should have done
nor hey you were obsessed with something and made an idol out of something that you shouldn't have
either so that everybody is that you got to find that balance the only way I know to find that balance
is to have that relationship with him that um I can hear his Holy Spirit tell me uh uh uh uh or
yes yes yes yes yes and um that's different for everyone that's that that's what a personal relationship is
and that is my biggest piece of advice for all of you don't trust everything I say don't trust
everything you read on the internet for sure don't trust everything you're oncologist says are
absolute and but ultimately you have to trust um what the Lord has said to you so read his word to
know that you can hear his voice so that you know that uh no my Heavenly Father wouldn't say that
you know I just know that I know him well enough because I studied his word enough that he wouldn't
tell me that but it's that still small voice that you need to be able to hear um his yays and
nays uncertain subjects that are necessarily written in scripture so have a little relationship so
that you know what to do that's my biggest advice for you and it will never end all right with that I
think we'll end for today thanks for being a part of our call and uh we'll get this up if you need
to listen any part of it again all right bye bye everybody